son las primeras declaraciones públicas
de la primera dama de haití desde el
magnicidio ella resultó herida de
gravedad desde el hospital de miami al
que le remitieron martino y publicó un
audio en twitter
estoy llorando es verdad pero no podemos
dejar que el país pierda su rumbo no
podemos dejar que la sangre del
presidente lleven el móvil
mi esposo nuestro mandatario a quien
quisimos y quien nos quiso se derrame en
vano
redoblaremos esfuerzos porque la lucha
que él dio no es personal es la batalla
que dio por todos nosotros la tenemos
que continuar con un
las autoridades haitianas culpan a un
comando de 26 colombianos y dos
haitianos estadounidenses por el
asesinato de moix
la primera dama sugirió que ellos fueron
enviados por sus enemigos políticos en
medio del creciente temor y la
inseguridad en el país cerca de 1000
personas se congregaron a las afueras de
la embajada de eeuu el viernes en busca
de un asilo político
no puedo dormir en las noches tuve que
venir aquí a la embajada porque tengo
miedo hay muchos tiroteos y ni siquiera
se sabe de dónde vienen las balas
hasta ahora el primer ministro claude
joseph ha manejado la respuesta ante el
homicidio pero el viernes
ariel en ree a quien nombró para
reemplazar a joseph y que no sea
posesionado anunció que él formaría un
nuevo gobierno pero yo sé parece tener
las fuerzas de seguridad de su lado y su
gobierno solicitó tropas de eeuu y de la
onu la casa blanca respondió que por
ahora enviar a agentes del fbi